at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O hey everybody what's going on
hopefully my mic phone is on I forgot to
check but yeah okay I guess it's on if
you guys can hear me so yeah it's uh me
solo again but happily here's the thing
so I see that some of you did not
realize um that uh Tom's dad actually
did pass away uh yesterday morning at
about 6:45 a.m. um I woke up about 7:30
I had stayed up until about one or two
like talking to him because he was
because Tom was in the
hospital uh you know kind of sitting
vigil you know and um I then I fell
asleep and then I woke up about 7:30 and
I saw the message so um so what had
happened initially Tom was going to stay
in Mississippi he wasn't sure how long
he was going to stay because he's like
well they are having a memorial service
but he's like I'm not sure when it is
he's like they're talking about maybe
Saturday or maybe next Monday and today
he just came and he's just like you know
what it's like they're not really sure
when it is and it's kind of too long and
and you know he's like I was there when
he passed away anyway the memorial
service is more for his friends um Tom
did actually get to spend time cuz he
was staying at his dad's house um with
his cousin Scott and um they did have
like other relatives and friends of his
dads like came and hung out with them
and talked to them and stuff because he
was sending me uh videos and stuff so
he's like so I you know I I don't know
if I can stay here that long so he
actually told me today I'm going to
start driving back today so so he is
actually at the moment of the stream he
is actually on his way back home right
now so he is driving back home right now
um I think from my calculations if the
traffic is not bad he should be back
between 11: and midnight I would think
so it's you know many hours probably
after the show is over but you know
hopefully I got a um he sent me a like a
voice
message about how long ago was that it
was probably like 3 or 4 hours ago and
he said that he was about 30 mil from
the Alabama Florida border um and then
after when you when you once you get
into the Florida Panhandle it's another
like 300 miles you know because Florida
is [__] enormous so we're thinking
that it'll be like between 11:00 and
midnight so hopefully he'll be home this
evening I was very excited uh when he
told me he was coming home today because
you know I was just kind of like cuz
when he was telling me maybe I have to
stay till Sunday and I was like oh no I
was getting like really depressed and
stuff but he's like no I don't he's like
I I don't really want to stay here that
long and he's like I have to get the
rental car back and stuff like that
because and you know so so he's on his
way back now hopefully uh it's a safe
journey and you know he should be back
in a few hours so yeah um he's doing
okay like Tom is he like I said he was
there his um cousin Scott was there his
a his aunt Christa was there uh they
were all in the room I said Tom sent me
a video um you know when he passed away
so they were there with him and he
didn't really know what was happening
like I said they just did um the
morphine and everything like that so it
was just they didn't he didn't even get
sent to hospice so he just died in the
hospital but um you know Tom is like
well he's like even when I went he's
like you know I knew that this was
probably what was going to happen and
you know that's so he's pretty Zen about
it uh he doesn't seem you know he's sad
but he's not not like upset he was
expecting it and he's just like well
it's just he he's gone to you know he's
in a better place basically because he
was in a lot of pain he did have a lot
of issues and you know he was just kind
of not um not having uh fun anymore
let's let's say it like that you know
and and I told him I said I went through
the same thing with my grandmother I
think I brought it up on the show before
she had stomach cancer and you know they
did surgery they thought they got it all
they didn't and they were like hey we
can do chemo she's like no I don't I
don't want to go through all that um you
know it's just it's too much so she just
kind
of um just kind of let it ride you know
what I mean so it's sad but you know Tom
seems okay with it and like I said I'm
really happy that he's coming home
hopefully he gets home safely this
evening uh after the show I'm definitely
going to sit up and wait because I'm you
know I'm not going to be able to sleep
until he gets back anyway because I'm
like worried so and I'm sure Pooky and
Bambi will be very happy to see him cuz
they Pooky is like Bambi is kind of like
you know we haven't had her that long we
only got Bambi like in August or
something and she has a weird
relationship with Tom she loves me it's
like she's I she won't even leave me
alone she's like my little Shadow all
the time I've I've tripped over her many
times because she'll go and like come
under my feet um she she's kind of like
if Tom starts petting her and stuff
she's like oh yeah that's the [__] right
there but then like a lot of times like
if Tom comes in the room she's like oh
[__] like he's a monster or something so
we don't know if somewhere she lived
before like maybe some man did something
to her I don't know but the weird thing
about it is that Pooky who's so used to
like wrestling with Tom and stuff like
that she is kind of confused she keeps
like jumping up on the bed like when I'm
sitting in there at night and like being
like looking over to the side like
where's he at you know what I mean like
what's going on and then like when I was
talking to him over like FaceTime or
whatever she kept like jumping up and
being like where's Daddy I can like I
hear his voice it's like why is he in
that tiny little device you know what I
mean so it's just like so they'll
probably be like happy to see him I'll
be happy to see them
but yeah so it's kind of
like uh you know it it's kind of a
bummer but like I said Tom knew it was
coming so he seems pretty chill about it
so whatever Ben said are the hurricanes
or whatever you had the other day
finished um yeah it wasn't a hurricanes
it was yeah this it's this is way past
hurricane season hurricane season runs
from June 1st to November
30th uh these were this was like a
really weird they were tornadoes is what
it was we didn't have um I don't know if
they were any close to us here in
Eustace it was just real like it was
just rainy and super super windy like
the rain was just like whacking into the
windows and stuff but we didn't have
like tornado force winds or anything and
our power didn't go out I know like some
people's did I saw like some of our
friends that live in kind of the Orlando
area and stuff I saw that their power
went out but ours did not um thank you
very much Julianne um safe travels to
Tom yeah we're we're all hoping for that
he's just you know I know he's driving
and he can't like update me but I'm
always just kind of like really nervous
like when he was driving that far CU I
when he was going there I was like send
me a message like the second you get
there because you know who knows what
could happen you know I'm just I I worry
about it he's like don't worry about it
it's fine but you know I worry about
[__] that's that's just kind of my thing
you know what I mean you can't help it
um uh hey Dave what's up it's like hey
John Tom could put YouTube on his cell
and listen to the show like I do
yeah he'll probably um he said on his
way there I think he listened to Wang on
the way there like on YouTube but uh cuz
he just had his he had his tablet so he
like hooked it up to the Bluetooth in
the car but um feeling sad for Tom yeah
like I said it's sad and I'm sad but you
know like like I said we kind of knew it
was coming I mean we've kind of been
expecting it I don't remember when it
was it was several years ago three or
four years ago when he went you know
when his dad got the bypass and we were
kind of expecting it then um you know
but we were really happy it's like oh
you know he he recovered you know what I
mean but um ever since then you know
like Tomic Callum every now and then
he's like man I don't think he's doing
too good and I really need to get out
there you know what I mean because you
know I don't know how much longer he's
going to be around so I'm just really
glad that because Tom actually wasn't
going to go to Mississippi until Monday
this past Monday um but then like when
his relatives called and said you know
he's really really not doing that good
so he actually just left Saturday like
he wasn't even planning to leave
Saturday but he's like yeah I better go
today so he went down rented the car and
everything and then he went so it's kind
of a good thing because his dad died
Tuesday morning like early Tuesday
morning so it's good that he got there
and that he was
there um Zach says maybe I should make
some coffee in my booze I'll have booze
and then I'll have I got a coffee pot
like right there I gu I got it right
there I got my folders black silk over
there and my and my pumpkin spice
creamer so that's what I'm going to have
um uh DVD Dragon said I never knew
Florida had tornadoes you were a badass
action State we have pretty other than
snow uh we have pretty much all yeah
with tidal wave flooding tornadoes
hurricanes well a lot of times you have
a a hurricane and the hurricane causes
tornadoes like a little lines of
tornadoes and [__] like that so you know
we have we have all the [__] which we
have giant flying cockroaches it's it's
a lot it's a lot big alligators you know
uh Danny said was Tom's dad awake so he
could talk to him or was he sedated the
whole time um I think they basically
from the time that Tom had sent me the
video which was Monday night at around
10 or 11 p.m. um he was so out of it
like so doped up that he didn't know
what was going on um and he showed him
his his blood pressure was like 47 over
20 or something like that like he showed
me the machine cuz they were just like
like sitting there in the dark but thank
you very much Victor that's very nice of
you yay it's the Jenny show yeah got to
be the Jenny show like I said Tom will
be home later tonight hopefully you know
if nothing bad
happens I'm just I'm stressing out but
you know what I mean I'm just happy that
he's coming home because I thought man
if I got to wait until Sunday or Monday
or whatever it's just like that's just
so depressing it's just I don't know I'm
just used to having him around you know
what I mean so like when he's not around
I'm always just kind of like I just
always feel like I'm I don't know it's
just really weird it's a weird feeling
and I get kind of bored cuz he's not
here to like talk to and stuff so that's
why actually doing the show cuz somebody
said like on the YouTube comment like
when I commented about it they're like
you know oh don't worry about doing the
show Wednesday night and everything like
that but I was like I wanted to because
it's like I like to talk to you guys you
know what I mean because other than that
I would just be sitting in the room with
Pokey like watching True Crime [__] on
Netflix or something you know what I
mean and I was just or like uh Hell's
Kitchen like like that's what I was
doing last night I was watching Hell's
Kitchen like just one episode after
another just wa with my little phone
right there like see and looked if there
were updates you know what I mean it's
that kind of [__] um but
yeah Zach says um something like yeah
Mega said Florida seems to have most of
the weather fun yeah it's it's super fun
uh Zach says going to need it overheard
dad yesterday saying my mom has 3 to six
months left so who boy yeah it's
I still my both of my parents are still
alive um but you know it's I know that
that day is coming my grandmother
recently died my uncle recently died um
my stepdad isn't doing too well either
so I don't know we'll kind of see how
it's
going uh mango said he will be fine
Jenny we're all here for you and Tom
well thank you very much thank you very
much like I said I worry I try not to
but and he tells me not to but I'm just
like that's telling me that it's just
that has no effect at all oh thanks I
won't except I still will you know what
I mean that's just what I was that's
that's how I do Camp gu said my old man
was Ill with um stage four gastri cancer
for 17 months I got to see him about
every 3 or four weeks when I traveled to
their house yeah it's always good to I'm
like I said I'm just so glad that Tom
got to go there and see him like when he
was still awake you know what I mean
when he was still awake and talking and
cuz like I said he seemed Monday he
seemed like he was getting a little bit
better you know what I mean cuz they
said oh he's he's actually doing okay
and then he kind of just declined like
as the night went on because like I said
I was even Monday night I was talking to
Tom on uh on FaceTime and you know he
was sitting in the room he's like yeah
we went to the thing today and he seem
to be doing like okay but maybe he's
declining some and then like his cousin
Scott came and knocked at the bedroom
door and was like we need to get back to
the hospital like right now so he's like
oh [__] I got to go you know what I mean
so then he was like sending me stuff
from the hospital so but you know it's
kind kind of
sad yeah Camp guy said I always asked
him if he was in any pain and he said no
he lived longer than the surgeon
predicted yeah I mean that happen
sometimes my grandmother lived longer
than they thought she would but you know
like I said she wasn't having a fun time
we we took care of her at home for a
long time she had a hospital bed there
um so and I only lived at that time I
only lived like less than a mile away so
a lot of times like before work cuz I
worked at night so I would come over in
the day and like hang out with her and
stuff but and we had other family
members that would come and take care of
her stuff while she was but in the end
she had to go to
hospice um yeah Tammy said yes I need
some people to talk to also I've done
nothing but clear out my mom's apartment
for the past two days yeah it's so you
really have to like give yourself a
break you know what I mean because it's
like you know i t I talk to Tom and
stuff but he's not here and it's just
kind of like you know I talk to Pooky
but she doesn't really talk back
exactly so so so it's kind of I'm
talking to myself I'm watching gter
Ramsey and like talking to myself
talking to the people on the TV and [__]
like that so you know it's kind of nice
to like be able to talk to you guys and
like have some interaction and [__] like
that but uh but yeah so I guess we'll
get into this topic in a minute before
we do that though we actually got a new
Patron we haven't had one of those in a
while um yeah we got a new Patron named
vashi hopefully I'm pronouncing that
correctly I think I've seen them in the
chat or commenting on the videos or
something like that cuz name was very
familiar so thank you very much for
becoming our latest Patron that's pretty
awesome they actually paid um you can do
this on patreon I think patreon they
just started this like not too long ago
well you can pay um like the entire year
you know what I mean you just pay for a
year like you know and it's kind of
cheaper than paying per month or
whatever I'm not really sure how they do
it but um but yeah they did that so
that's pretty cool also one of our
listeners named mut uh sent us this book
right here here cuz they had recommended
that we do a show about the glennen uh
Manor mansion glennen mansion murders
which I had actually never heard of it's
like a true crime case and so they sent
a book about it and it just got here the
other day they had sent me a message
like and it's like hey what's you guys'
mailing address and it's like I totally
did not see it for like two weeks and
I'm like oh my God I feel like such an
[__] but it's just kind of like I
have so many things that I check and
sometimes I forget like it's like so if
you send me stuff on Facebook or
Instagram or whatever like sometimes
I'll it but sometimes I forget to check
them so you know so if I don't get back
to you right away I'm not being a dork
I'm just I mean I'm not being a jerk I'm
just being forgetful is what I'm being
um but yeah so this is cool hopefully we
can do a show about this one of these
days because I know absolutely nothing
about this case and hadn't heard about
it happened in um
Minnesota in duth Minnesota so yeah I'm
going to read that and hopefully we'll
get to do a show about that one of these
days so this topic right here
um I have to say was it Danny that
recommended it I'm not really sure I
think it might have been um so I put it
in the polls and like I said now I we
did the poll this week uh you know if
you're on our patreon or if you're a
YouTube member um you know I put up a
poll every week with like five different
topics and you can vote on whatever we
do so the topic that won this week
easily was Jeffrey Epstein but like I
said I wanted Tom to be here for for
that so I was like if I have to do show
by myself then I'm going to then I'm not
going to do Jeffrey Epstein I'm going to
do so I did the second uh Second Place
finisher which was this so what we're so
there won't be a poll this upcoming week
like on patreon or on the YouTube
Community tab um we're just going to do
the show about Jeffrey Epstein next
Wednesday because some will be back by
then that'll give me more time to
research it too like I've watched the
Netflix series and all that but you know
what I mean I kind of want to get more
into it so you know so that's how that's
going to go so this was the second place
finisher and this I have to say this
topic was a [__] to research because
there's really not much about this I
kind of feel like what happened and I'm
not sure if this is the timeline this is
the timeline that
I figured out like just from looking at
the dates things were posted I think
what happened with this was that um
there was a viral video that came out in
August of
2023 and then people kind of went back
and started researching the [__] that
the video was talking about um and then
so so you know what I mean so there's
not really a lot about it that's newer
than that because it seems like that's
kind of the newest thing and if you if
you Google NASA Zone F you're gonna get
the pretty much the top thing is that
Tik Tok video and other people talking
about that Tik Tok video you know what I
mean um there's not a lot of information
about it outside of that but I don't
know it but it was kind of interesting
like the more down the rabbit hole I
went into but like I said it was really
hard to research because there's not a
lot of information about it but I did
kind of try and find
out what the whole timeline of it was um
yeah mango said this was the topic I
voted for yeah this turned out to be
like more interesting than I thought cuz
like when I started to to research it I
was just kind of like oh my God there's
like nothing about this or it's like
what is this even about and then like
then I started kind of getting deeper
into it and I was like oh okay this is
kind of interesting though but you know
what I mean
it's I guess because it's kind of new
but not I don't know it it's kind of
hard to explain but uh but yeah so let's
I guess we'll just get into it cuz like
I said I'm going to um you know do the
show for however along and then uh after
I sign off I'll maybe go and have
another drink and wait for time to come
home and worry like I do like I'll sit
there with my little phone like next to
me like keep looking at it keep looking
at it make sure that he's like all right
you know what I mean so uh but yeah like
I said I'm expecting him home between
11: and midnight Eastern Standard Time
so hopefully he'll get home if he gets
home like I'll maybe I'll post on a
YouTube Community tab or on the Facebook
page or something like that so everybody
knows that he got home safely cuz like I
said I worry about it and maybe I'll
worry about it too but uh but yeah so
okay so here's what I could determine
about this NASA Zone F thing which has
to do with megalodons which I I was
thinking NASA Zone f is this some kind
of weird I had no idea what it was and
then I figured it's like what does it
have to do with megalodons I was like
why did Megalodon stuff keep coming up
so it's just like so so this is what I
figured out okay about this um
so oh they talking about oh wildfires
yeah yeah
yeah yeah we have wildfires too all the
time actually uh several years ago there
was really bad wild wildfires when I
still lived at my grandmother's house in
Daytona and they were like a mile behind
our house like they evacuated us they
were like you guys got to get out of
here and the house didn't burn down
thankfully but a bunch of other ones did
like but you went outside and there was
just ash raining down it looked like the
end of the world or something it was
crazy but yeah that was years and years
ago but it does happen and actually even
recently when I used to drive to Daytona
for work like last year um probably like
once a week there'd be like some big
fire like right along um you know us92
so there like there'd be smoke all over
the road and there'd be signs everywhere
sorry there's fire again you know what I
mean they even have like the little
Smokey Bear sign out there it says F you
know Wildfire risk high today you know
what I mean it's that so yeah we have
those two we don't really have
earthquakes um or if we do they're so
small that you don't notice them but we
have all the other fun things tornadoes
hurricanes floods sink holes wildfires
it's it's a lot like I said giant
roaches so okay so I think this this is
where the the whole Zone F thing
started so August of
2023 um there was a viral Tik Tok video
and it was uploaded by a user named
forbidden combo I think that was their
username now as of today this video has
over 27 million views a
lot I do have the video but I'm going to
show it to you later so according to
this
video in April of
2023 there was a guy who was like a
diver uh sailor person named George
Meyer and he was out on a fishing trip
off the coast of
Maryland uh with his friend I think and
then this big huge storm came up and
blew their boat like um a long way off
course right they ended up who knows
where well they knew where cuz they have
GPS it's the 21st century but you know
what I mean so after they end up
wherever they end up and the weather
gets better George looks down the side
of the ship like or boat or whatever to
check the engines and he sees what
appears to be the top of an enormous
cage just beneath the surface of the
water so he's like huh I wonder what on
Earth that could be so he puts on his
diving gear and goes down to have a look
at
it now apparently he swims down to a
depth of
feet we'll get back to that
later uh now the cage according to this
video was so large that he could not see
the outer boundaries of it like you
couldn't see how big it was now
conveniently while he was swimming
around this cage he also saw like this
horizontal bar one of the horizontal
bars on the cage uh there's a picture
over in the video um that says on it
Zone F property of NASA stay
out he also claimed that swimming around
inside this cage was a shark that
appeared to be about 70 ft
long so there you
go so he goes back to the surface
apparently and he's able to get the boat
back home now evidently he went back to
the same spot 2 weeks later but he could
not find the cage again this Tik Tock
video also claimed that back in the
1970s NASA spent um just an exorbitant
amount of money on this secret gigantic
enclosed habitat off the coast of
Maryland where they studied rare and
endangered species including the last
Megalodon which is apparently the big
ass shark that George Meyer
saw so I'm sure everybody knows this but
Megalodon was a huge huge [__]
prehistoric
shark um and live from about 23 million
years ago to about 2.6 million years ago
um this was the lived during the masine
and the pine uh Epoch now the largest of
the Megalodons they think were little
less than 60 feet long which is a big
[__] shark if you didn't know uh so
they were the largest sharks and
actually the largest fish to ever exist
so you know they did exist there there
is
that now the when this video went viral
on Tik
Tok it seems to have fueled some
conspiracy theories about NASA hiding
the fact that
megalodons still
exist now obviously this was not the
first video that purported to say that
uh there were a lot of things like
priming people to believe that I think
um you know probably the most obvious
thing like nowadays would be you know
the movies the Meg and the Meg 2 which
are about a Megalodon um although I have
to say that those movies were based on
books like the first book um the first
movie The Meg was actually based on a
1997 novel um called the Meg called it's
just called Meg like a novel of deep
Terror uh and the author's name is Steve
Alton and he wrote like a bunch of
sequels so like I said they they are
actually based on books so there was
kind of that idea floating around uh
before
that um also and we've talked about this
before uh sadly in context of Tom's dad
um because Tom's dad totally did believe
this thing so in back in
2012 Animal Planet made a do documentary
or a mockumentary as they call it called
mermaids the Body Found now in this fake
documentary um there was actually uh
footage quote unquote of uh of a fight
like uh between a bunch of mermaids like
a pod of mermaids I guess you would call
it and a Megalodon now this is said to
have occurred 1.6 million years ago
which like I said is more more recent
than they than Megalodon went extinct
obviously now later on in
2013 the Discovery Channel you know they
do shark week every you know year and so
in that year they actually their big uh
draw that year was this another fake
documentary called Megalodon the monster
shark
lives now when this came out um a lot of
scientists and stuff like that were
really mad because they're like um this
documentary is fake but Discovery didn't
really just like the mermaids one but
Discovery didn't really um try too hard
to tell people that it was fake you know
what I mean I think they had like a tiny
little disclaimer like in there
somewhere um but yeah it so it was just
kind of the thing where you know like
there was just actors portraying
scientists and all this other kind of
stuff but it was like complete [__]
it was just like this other one I
watched one when we were doing the show
about the mythology of dragons and there
was one it was British I think and it
was obviously fake because dragons
aren't real um but they tried to make it
seem like an actual documentary so they
made it seem like a nature documentary
this is how dragons evolved like fire
breathing and like the wings and
everything like that so it was kind of
neat like the way they did it but I
could see how people that maybe weren't
that bright were like watching it and
being like holy [__] dragons are real
you know what I mean because I don't
know I like to think that people
wouldn't fall for a documentary about
mermaids being real especially in 2012
for Christ's sake but apparently a lot
of people
did and the thing about it is that and
the Megalodon one was probably like even
worse in that regard because megalodons
did exist I mean they know that like
mermaids obviously didn't exist but it's
just kind of you know but megalodons did
exist so it's not that crazy to say it's
like oh yeah maybe there are a few of
them still around or something like that
so a lot of people did kind of fall for
that and scientists were kind of pissed
because they're like you know this was
completely fake and you didn't really
tell people that it was fake so a lot of
people kind of fell for it so I mean
they did a poll like later on and they
said that 73% of the people that watched
it like thought that Megalodon was still
around so like I said so it's so it's
kind of
persuasive so they they made another one
called Megalodon the New Evidence which
I think was also fake and then they had
another one and I love the [__] title
of this I I kind of want to watch this
now just because I love the title so
much it's called Shark of Darkness why
did they not call it sharkness I don't
know Shark of Darkness wrath of
Submarine that was another one that they
called it um so yeah and again
scientists were mad about that cuz
they're like what the [__] are you doing
it's like we told you to quit that and
you keep doing it well it's like the
reason they kept doing it was because
the mockumentary about the Megalodon was
like one of their highest rated Pro well
was their highest rated Shark Week
program like ever um they got like 5
million viewers or something like that
which is a lot for Discovery show and it
was more than like any other shark week
so they're like well obviously we're
going to make it because people are
watching it they don't give a [__] if
like people think it's real you mean
it's like that's their problem if
they're dumb you know what I mean so so
I kind of feel like okay so when this
Tik Tok video dropped in 2023 um that
was saying you know NASA has this thing
called Zone F that's this big cage like
under
the the ocean like by Maryland and they
keep all this stuff in it including a
Megalodon I don't know what else they
keep in there I couldn't really find any
other information on that but um but
there was a Megalodon in there so um so
I guess people were kind of primed to
believe it like I said because it was
kind of in the
Zeitgeist so what I would imagine I
don't know if this is exactly what
happened but this is what I would
imagine probably happened so when the
Tik Tok video went viral in in 2023 I
guess people were just kind of like holy
[__] Megalodons are still around and
then they started doing Google searches
about you know de Megalodon still exist
and blah blah so I'm assuming because
that's what I Googled I wanted to see
what came up and so I'm assuming that
they came
across kind of the same articles that I
did which had like super clickbaity
headlines like there was one from
Newsweek that was older like it came out
in uh August of 2019 and the headline
reads moner shark bigger than a
submarine filmed by scientists as it
tries to eat their gun I mean that's a
great headline um we'll get into what
actually happened later on but yeah so
so yeah uh there was also another
article this one was from September 20th
2022 and that was from Staten Island
live and it said massive 50 foot
Megalodon detected in Atlantic Ocean
leaves scientists stunned even though
Megalodon was in quotes I think people
still were like holy [__] they found a
me because if all you read was the
headline then you'd probably be like
holy [__] they still exist you know what
I mean and before
that um in 2021 I don't remember what
month it was but there was another Tik
Tok video that went viral
also and in this one um there was a huge
shark and it was kind of spotted from a
research ship off the coast of
Massachusetts and so the video of this
like I said like got millions and
millions of views now this video was
actually taken from the SSV cor with
Kramer which is a research ship um from
the sea Education
Association so they were out on a
mission whatever it was they were doing
and they noticed this huge [__] shark
like swiming next to the ship um now the
guy that recorded it whose name was Alex
alre who was like a member of the team
that's whose um account it was posted
under that was the username and um it
just went crazy like in it you can see I
actually have that somewhere where is
this I have that video it's this
one yeah so that's a pretty big [__]
shark there that they're
seeing um but yeah this got millions of
views when it came out and you can't I
turned the sound off but basically you
can just hear but going holy [__] you
know what I mean because it was this big
[__] uh shark there so yeah so so
there's that so that um video also
fueled uh cuz I think even you can hear
somebody on the video like jokingly
saying oh my God is that a
Megalodon you know what I mean so like I
said it's kind of in the zeit guys at
this point like everybody's thinking oh
my God they're still like out there you
know what I
mean so apparently uh according to
sources that I
read um this shark the sighting of it
because people thought holy [__] it's
it's big it might be Megalodon so
somebody somewhere I'm not sure where
and like I said I'm not sure if this is
entirely true cuz like I said there's
not a lot of information about this um
so people were kind of concerned so they
contacted NASA to check this
out now why NASA you might be asking
yourself aren't they a space thing yes
but you know NASA's whole thing is
they're supposed to understand space and
to understand space you also have to
understand Earth and to understand in
Earth you also have to understand the
oceans so apparently NASA has been
studying oceans like from satellites and
things like that for a very long time
and um you know obviously they get
satellite images of uh the oceans and
like are kind of helping to uh monitor
phenomena various phenomena that's going
on in the ocean you know for scientific
purposes um you know one of the things
that they do for example is um they
actually collaborate with the O the wood
Woods Hole oceanographic
institution and they're exploring um the
the deepest zones of the ocean The hatle
Zone um because they're hoping to
because they're comparing like the
extreme environments like underwater
like the high pressure and everything
like that to May environments you might
encounter in space so it kind of helps
them um you know study different
environments that they might encounter
like on you know Europa like Jupiter's
moon or whatever like that so it so you
can see why they that information would
be useful to them so NASA has been
studying the oceans for quite a long
time so it's not crazy like so you can
see where the idea of Zone F came from
you know it's not just out of left field
that I mean it's kind of out of left
field that they'd have a cage underneath
Maryland but it's not at a left left
field that they would be studying the
oceans because they do and they've been
doing that for a really long
time so what's the deal with all of this
stuff like all of these articles and
these videos and and everything like
that um you know does a me can Megalodon
still exist like is NASA covering it up
yada yada most likely no and no I think
the answers to both of those questions
are probably no I'm going to say if NASA
is covering it up they're doing a really
[__] good job because there's barely
anything about this but here's the thing
um okay so let's take things kind of
Point by point we'll start with that
2021 tick to video of the big ass shark
by the ship that I just showed you I'll
show it to you again if you want to see
it again uh there it is that shark
swimming there by the boat uh this was
posted on Tik Tok in uh
2021 by Alex alch who is one of the guys
on the ship obviously um and they were
all like freaking out about it so like I
said that is a big [__] shark so
let's start with that
now um is this video
real um yes as far as I could
determine uh is that a Megalodon no that
is not a Megalodon that there is a
basking shark uh is what that is and
they are big they typically get about 26
feet long which is big uh they're
actually the second largest living fish
after the whale shark um but not as big
as a Megalodon which like I said they
got about 60 ft almost 60 ft
the Megalodon did so yes that is a real
shark but it's not a Megalodon it's a
basking shark which are big and scary
but the thing about basking sharks is
they're massive but just like the whale
shark which is even bigger than a
basking shark they um don't eat people
they're planks and feeders so even
though they're big and scary and I would
probably [__] my pants if I if one pass
me in the ocean just cuz they're so
massive uh they won't eat you like like
Jaws you know what I mean cuz they don't
even they just have that big that thing
where they just go through the ocean and
you know what I mean just like eat all
the little bitty stuff so they so
they're not going to eat them they might
swallow you on purpose if they're on
accident I mean but you know they'd
probably be like they'd split spit you
out they're not going to be like jaws
and like bite your legs off or
nothing
so tmy said maybe it's a baby mag play
Devil's Advocate it's possible that's
that's that's a possibility I had not
considered because that seems like it's
always kind of like the movie you know
what I mean where it's just like did you
guys see um the Irish uh Kaiju movie
gorgo it was on MST that's where I saw
it so it's like an Irish Godzilla pretty
much it's not bad uh actually and so
it's just very much like the Trope of
the of the big monster movies where it's
just like they catch one and they're
like wow look at this it's stomping all
around all over this like all over
Ireland or whatever and then they
capture it and they put it in a circus
and then um they figure out oh no it's
just a baby and then like it's big ass
mom like comes and just like give me my
baby back and it's like stomping through
London and everything like that so it's
pretty fun it's like I said it's not as
good as Godzilla it's kind of cheesy but
um but I don't know I kind of like it
it's funnier on MST though because they
make all kind of jokes about the guy
that runs the circus his name is Dorking
that's his last name and maybe that's
the last name in the UK that's pretty
common but you know I I just can't not
giggle at that sorry and neither could
they I mean they just kept making jokes
about it it it wasn't dork it was DOR
dorkin so yeah without the G it was
dorkin that's that was his Circus dorkin
Circus and I was just like I'm not going
to a circus called dorkin
Circus I'm just not yeah Jeffy said I
love gorgo especially the MST 3K version
it's so good it's one of my favorite
episodes like all of the I think one of
my favorite lines from it is um because
I like when they try to do accents and
stuff and uh this one guy like comes in
the
thing there's just in the harbor
Master's uh house or whatever and he
comes in and there's all this stuff and
um I think one of them said what do he
he says something like
uh he says it in Irish accent I think
Crow said it's like me mom's on vacation
so I'm having a garage sale with all her
stuff or something like that I don't
know just the way he said it was like
super funny but yeah it's
um it it's something so this possibly
could be a baby Meg and maybe it was
just going on but how awesome would it
have been if at the end of that video
that the the big shark by the side he
just went kind of under like that and
then this big [__] shark comes out
just like in the in the movie The make
but yeah that's could have been
that okay so so that like I said was a
real video that was a real shark but it
wasn't a Megalodon it was a basking
shark so what about the Newsweek article
uh that said there was a monster shark
bigger than submarine so if you read the
article which was actually there were
versions of it printed um in lots of
different uh science magazines and
things like
that uh this encounter was also real um
and was actually pretty cool but this
was also not a
Megalodon um this particular fish that
they saw was actually a very rare shark
that was called that's called the
bluntnose six Gill they call it a six
Gill because it has six skills instead
of the normal five obviously and it has
a blunt nose so that's why they call it
that very on the very on the nose that
name is so um this is a actually a very
ancient species of shark um and they
think maybe that it
represents um what might be the oldest
living lineage of sharks uh in the world
this lineage goes back about 180 million
years now the researchers in this
submarine who saw the shark could they
took pictures and video of it and stuff
like that because like I said it's very
rare um and you don't you see them that
often so they were pretty excited about
it um they did say it was huge they did
call it a monster um they said it was
longer than the sub but that's not quite
as impressive as it sounds cuz the sub
wasn't actually all that big you know
what I mean um it the the shark I
believe was only about 20 feet long
which is big I mean that's a big shark
but again it's not 60
ft also the shark um tried to eat a
spear gun so there's that
which I thought was kind of I'm like
that's kind of cute I don't I think the
spear gun was like on somebody like
because maybe one of the divers was
outside of the sub and the shark was
just kind of like huh what's that I
think I'm going to eat this sharp sharp
thing and I was like okay sharks shark's
not the brightest I
guess you know what I mean yeah six
kills are super ancient yeah they are
and so that's why they were excited
because it well not only cuz it was big
cuz they're like holy [__] you hardly
ever see those you know what I mean cuz
they're um it's very just rare to to see
them so there was also the thing about
um that was on Staten Island live which
was about the headline read massive 50
foot Megalodon again it was in quotes uh
detected in Atlantic Ocean now this one
if you read the article this turned out
to like not even be a shark and honestly
from the tone of the article not from
the tone of the article but from the
tone of the quotes of the scientists
that saw it on the ship um I think they
were kind of making it a joke you know
what I mean like saying oh my God it's a
Megalodon you know what I mean but they
didn't really I mean they didn't really
think it was that's at least what the
tone seemed like to
me so um so the article says it's okay
so these researchers are in the
Northwest Atlantic Ocean and they
detected what appeared to be a 50ft
Megalodon um on their scanners like it
was below their boat like it looked like
a big 50ft fish right um so they posted
on Instagram uh this was the Atlantic
shark Institute by the way the
researchers were from and uh his
Instagram post under the video it says
on a recent shark research trip we were
all amused so like I said they were
amused they weren't like horrified or
shocked or baffled or anything like that
like some of the headlines normally say
we were all amused to see this shape
appear on our fish finder for several
minutes based on the length of the image
we estimated the med to be about 50 ft
long weighing for weighing in at 40 tons
so that's what he wrote so you can tell
from this post that he didn't really
think it was a Megalodon he was just
like joking you know what I mean like he
thought it was a Megalodon because it
turned out that this and they probably
knew this as well that this was not a
single fish um it was actually a huge
School of mackerel is what it was they
were all like clumped together and they
said that stayed by their boat for about
15 minutes and then that kind of started
to disperse a little bit so obviously
you could tell that it was a school of
mackerel and not one big fish but like I
said I'm sure that uh scientists who do
this kind of research out you know this
kind of field research I'm sure they see
that kind of [__] all the time so
they're not going to like flip out and
be like holy [__] it's a Megalodon you
know what I mean because it's probably
just like a big school of fish that
happens to be swimming in a
configuration that kind of looks like
one big fish and that's exactly what
this was so so that's what I'm saying I
kind of feel like and this is kind of
true across all media obviously they
want people to click on the [__]
article um the problem being that if you
have like a click baity article like
that even though they put Megalodon in
quotes I think for a dumb person that's
not really going to mean anything and I
think that a lot of people also just
read headlines and they don't read the
actual article where it says it wasn't a
Megalodon it was just a bunch of other
fish you know what I mean um so yeah so
if you just kind of went through and
said does Megalodon exist you would just
see all these headlines that made it
seem like there was Megalodon still
around you know what I mean so I think
that might be what happened as
well so okay so so much for that that
was also not a Megalodon but what about
the video that kind of probably started
this whole brewhaha to start with which
was the 2023 one um from Tik Tok now I'm
going to just show this because I have
this one I download it from Tik
Tok and where is it there it is like I
said I turned the sound down but it has
uh captions so the captions are just
saying what the narrator is saying so
this is it right here I think it's only
a minute and a half long or something
like that um and this is kind of like I
said they're saying they spent all their
money like this big underwater enclosure
off the coast of Maryland there it is uh
Zone f is what they're calling it and
they're conducing conducting research on
endangered
species so there's the person who
supposedly found it this was when it
happened there's his book boat with his
friends on it and all this other stuff
there's big
storm but yeah so here's all these
pictures
M I'm having a drink while the thing is
going sees a cage on which that looks
photoshopped but
yeah there he goes in his little diving
suit this watching this video because I
wanted to see the original one so I went
to the original gu uh thing and looked
at it and I was just like I can't
believe that anybody like thought this
was real but like I said people thought
the mermaid [__] was real on Discovery
too so and I watched that and I was just
like well that's very obviously fake but
I don't know some people will fall for
anything I don't really know but yet
this to me just seems very very
obviously fake um and I'll get
into a breakdown of it like as soon as
it's over and there's the Megalodon
swimming around in there there that he
saw on a shark and that's that's a very
helpful little guide there for how big
they actually are um yeah and it quickly
SW oh [__] it's a
dude then he goes back and he couldn't
find it two weeks later as I mentioned
before so that was the video that kind
of went viral now please note if you did
not go if you just saw this posted
somewhere else cuz a lot of news media
did um cover this and like just put the
so if you didn't go to the actual um
user that had posted it whose name is
forbidden
combo um his little Channel or whatever
they call it on Tik Tok I'm not really
sure because I'm old but um the tagline
underneath the username reads and this
is a quote fun and fictional mythical
creature stories that's what it says um
he's got a [__] ton of Megalodon videos
on there he's got ones about other um
extinct animals too like the Smilodon
and things like that um and he's got
ones about like a bunch of other
different Cryptids like here's this
person was driving like a train at night
and there was this thing that looked
like a w too or something like on the
tracks it was that kind of stuff uh and
there was even one uh just in time for
Christmas that claimed that someone got
footage of the real Santa Claus coming
down the chimney so this is clearly from
looking at all the other videos that
he's posted this is clearly a a
fictional like a thing about mythical
creatures and Cryptids and they're not
meant to be taken as real is what that
is um all of the accounts followers uh
at least the people that commented on
the videos seem to be in on the joke um
so and like I said it says fun and
fictional mythical creature stories
right there in the tagline um but you
can see that if somebody just posted
this elsewhere without any context um I
kind of feel like that happens a lot
like people post stuff from like satire
sites but if you don't know that it came
from a satire site or if it's from a
satire site that people don't know as a
satire site then people like take it
seriously and I think this might have
been a case of what happened here so but
if you're still not convinced that this
video is very blatantly fake and
purposefully fake fake they weren't
making it I mean he wasn't making it to
try and fool anybody into thinking it
was real I mean because his channel is
you know he it says right there that
it's fiction
so like I said it's like a satire and
it's kind of not his fault if people
didn't do their due diligence you know
what I mean um but if you still think
it's real so like every I mean obviously
if you're watching it every image in
this video is a stock photo or a picture
you know just taken off the internet
somewhere um when the guy that
supposedly saw this cage whose name is
George Meer when he's kind of introduced
in the video that picture that they show
of the guy holding the fish that's not
George Meyer that's just a random ass
photo um this particular George Meyer
that's in this video does not seem to
exist the guy that they're talking about
uh yeah there are a lot of people named
that but um that is not a picture of him
uh that's just a random ass photo that
doesn't have anything to do with anybody
named George Meyer um and uh I also saw
pointed out that apparently how they
ended up where the cage was cuz they
didn't just see it when they were fiddle
farting around where they were supposed
to be they apparently got blown way off
course I don't know where because
obviously the video doesn't say and
there's no other source for it um so it
was apparently this really really bad
storm that blew them off course to where
he saw the cage um but looking at you
know weather for the area for April 17th
which was the date um there were no bad
storms in that area at that time um so
that's another kind of
ding um also and I brought this up
earlier uh one part part of the story is
that when he saw the top of the
cage um he put on his diving [__] and
Dove down to see where the cage went he
Dove down 600
feet
now on land 600 feet is not really that
big of a deal however when you're
diving uh 600 fet is a very big
deal if you recreational divers um
generally you do not go deeper than 130
feet recreational divers do not um so if
you were just diving you wouldn't and
you wouldn't dive down to that you
wouldn't even dive down to that depth by
yourself either um after 130 ft that
becomes a technical dive um so it's
obviously more experienced
people um and train divers can obviously
go deeper than 600 ft
but there's a lot of uh [__] that you
have to do because of decompression
sickness obviously because if you come
up from 600t too fast you're going to
explode pretty much uh because of the
pressure so one example that I saw and
this wasn't 600 feet but it was like
deeper than this um you know because
your body has to return to it depends on
how long you have to come because you
know you have to come back up a little
bit and then wait and then come back up
a little bit and wait and because
depending on how deep you went um you
know how long long ago it was that you
Dove before because your body takes a
few days to get back its gas balance and
everything like that so there's a lot of
things you have to take into
consideration when you're diving that
deep um so there's the guy that whose
name I can't pronounce um ahed something
and he um gabber I think is how you
pronounce his last name or or gabber I'm
not really sure um I'm sure I'm
pronouncing it wrong but he actually
broke the scuba diving depth record and
he Dove down to to 1,90 Ft however it
took him 14 minutes to get down to that
depth and it took 14 hours to get back
up because of the
decompression so diving down 600 feet
just for shits and giggles to look at a
cage um that's not going to happen
that's not going to happen because it
would take you like a really really long
time to get back up you wouldn't just do
that [__] around and you wouldn't go
down there by yourself doing that also I
saw somebody else point out that it's
like oh how convenient that he just
happened to dive down on the part of the
cage that had property of NASA or
whatever like on the side of it because
if you notice there was like a picture
which like I said again was very
obviously photoshopped at least it it to
me it was very obviously photoshopped
because I've used Photoshop for 25 years
but um but yeah that's really unless it
was printed you know every two feet or
something like that it would be really
coincidental that he happened to come
across that one place where it said that
like on this massive [__] cage so
there's that too um so yeah so the video
claims like I said that in the course of
NASA's early research in the ocean that
they built this massive underwater cage
in the North Atlantic off the coast of
Maryland as I mentioned now in the video
they said it was visible from the
surface and went down a whole bunch of
feet now I'm assuming that if they
wanted to keep this a secret which I'm
which the video is positing that they
did why would they make it visible from
the surface and it's like and in
addition to that um if it was that close
to the surface then it would then there
would be like a a risk to ships like in
the area right because it's right there
so that seems kind of dumb like why
would they do that not really
sure um so now the the video claims that
this caged in area is called Zone F but
as I mentioned unless NASA is super good
at covering stuff up like better than
anybody covering anything up ever um
there is actually absolutely zero
evidence of anything that's called that
um so I think I don't know if this is
just something that I don't think they
made it up because there is something
called that but because here's the thing
like I said you do a Google search on
NASA Zone F or something like that like
online um most of the [__] that comes up
is this Tik Tok video and people talking
about this Tik Tok video you know what I
mean um like and it's some of a couple
of like Paranormal sites and stuff like
that um now the ocean does have zones
obviously um but they're not called
they're not lettered you know what I
mean they don't call them Zone A B C D
they call them various other things like
pelagic or whatever they call them other
stuff so they're not called Zone F now I
will note that in
my in my dig down the rabbit hole I did
find something called the fzone in
relation to NASA uh or at least
mentioned on a NASA website but they
didn't invent it and it doesn't have
anything to do with secret government
projects or anything either all it's
talking about is the boundary between
the inner and outer core of the
earth and honestly I could only find one
or two references like in a like in the
abstract of paper or something like that
where somebody referred to that area as
the F Zone you know what I mean and it
wasn't Zone f it was fzone with f in
quotation marks um I really could only
find one or two references and normally
people wouldn't call it that they would
just call it the the inner outer
boundary or the core boundary or
whatever but I did see like one abstract
of a paper that called it the fzone that
was pretty much all that came up but it
doesn't have anything to do with the
ocean really it's just kind of like you
know it's and it's nothing to do with
obviously Megalodon's inside
cages or anything like that so so as I
said if NASA did want to keep this a
secret they're doing a pretty good job
of hiding it because there's absolutely
[__] nothing about it Tammy said can
you imagine being that poor guy in the
picture I was wondering I should have
done a um a reverse Google image search
um I imagine that's probably a stock
photo or it might have been a photo that
somebody stole off somebody's Facebook
page or the person that made the video
on Tik Tok might the be a relative or
something like that but it's just kind
of like but there's nobody that it's not
George Meyer that's not that person so
uh yeah James naap said uh 100 feet is a
big deal for certifications yeah and
it's just like as soon as I watched the
Tik Tok video and they said Dove down
600 feet I'm like what 600 feet I'm like
I don't think so but you know what I
mean I mean if they wanted to make it
believable see that's why I think that
they weren't this channel like I said
not only does it say like fictional
mythical creature stories um I don't
think they were intending for anyone to
take this seriously so the fact that
they said yeah you Dove down 600 feet
like it wasn't no thing um I think that
was kind of maybe part of the joke I
thought I mean that's kind of how I took
it but maybe not maybe people think you
can just like jump in and dive down 600
feet like it's nothing but you can't
so yeah you'll get the bz big time yeah
your [__] lungs will you'll just like
pop like a [__] soda can when you
come up
Ben says maybe this guy is the
beneficiary of s secret military super
soldier technology yeah uh Danny rling
said in the next Godzilla film they
should show him taking out a Megalodon
they totally should actually yeah he's
never really fought a Megalodon has he
I'm surprised that hasn't happened yet
unless I I imagine I know that there's
like a lot of knockoff um like Asylum
level movies about megalodons you know
because ever when the Meg came out and
actually prior to that because um even
after the discovery fake documentary
came out about the Megalodons
everybody's like ooh Megalodon and they
just you know what I mean cuz if you
look at tub and if you look at all of
the um like shitty shark movies and
stuff there's 40 bajillion
like cheap ass shark movies we even
reviewed a couple of them like Ouija
shark which is terrible don't watch that
it's a well it's just it's not terrible
terrible it's just
not they could have done so much more
with that premise it was just
disappointing you know what I mean I was
like why couldn't they have done like
velocipastor where it's just like where
it actually like lived up to its idea
cuz Ouija shark that's a great idea you
know what I mean like it's a ghost shark
you can summon a ghost shark through a
Ouija board that's hilarious but it's
just like it wasn't it wasn't funny
enough like I said if you're going to
have a cool premise like that it better
be [__] zany like do everything you
can with it make it crazy and it just
wasn't crazy enough you know I think
that was my problem with it I think that
was my problem it's just it was a fun
premise that they kind of wasted
um Samy said it's called Zone [__]
this um oh yeah tequil said did get the
pass yeah yeah yeah um yeah you weren't
here earlier but yeah I showed it yeah I
got it I got it yeah we need to do a
show about this we need to do a show
about that yeah I showed it at the
beginning of the
show uh Danny said tonight's show Jenny
debunks the NASA own have conspiracy no
one's going to listen to me nobody cares
well like I said there's not really a
lot about this maybe it's just because
the Tik Tok video went viral um you know
just a few months ago um I would have
thought that there would have been a
bunch I did find some stuff talking
about like on a paranormal site like I
said um but there was and maybe I don't
know I was kind of like looking on
YouTube and it looked like maybe Joe
Rogan [__] kept coming up and I'm like
man I'm not watching Joe Rogan so you
know I mean so so I don't know if he
talked about it or not because I
couldn't bring myself to listen to it
but um but there wasn't really much else
about it I think there was one video
that was like seven or eight minutes
long with a guy like showing the Tik Tok
video and showing kind of why it was
[__] but there wasn't
really that much more about it that's
why I was kind of confused at first I'm
like how oh my God how am I going to do
a show about this there's like nothing
you know what I mean so if it was a
cover up it's a [__] good one that's
all I can say there's like cuz no I
don't know it like I said I'm not a big
conspiracy theory person I know there's
smaller conspiracies like obviously they
exist but some of these big like
overarching
conspiracies where thousands and
thousands of people would have to be
involved and you know nothing ever leaks
out um I just think that's really really
super unlikely and for a lot of the
reasons um that I stated before about it
the whole idea of just building this
giant cage that would
have you know rare species in it one
even if they were doing that that
doesn't seem super nefarious to me um
you know studying endangered species and
rare animals even if there were ones
that people everybody thought was
extinct it's like that doesn't seem
that's not like super villain [__] or
anything like that you know it's not
like they're building a thing that'll
blow up the Earth or nothing um it's
just yeah we're just studying animals
big deal you know that's not evil or
nothing so but even if they were doing
that which they very well may be it just
seems like going about it by building a
cage right there like it just seems like
inefficient and maybe not the best way
to go about it and why would they keep
it a secret
that's another thing I mean you would
think if they found a [__]
Megalodon they would we found a [__]
Megalodon you know what I mean that that
would be all over the [__] place they
get all kind of funding and [__] like
that so it's like why would they hide
that it's just I don't know so that
that's the problem I have with a lot of
conspiracy theories is if you think
about it's like you know why would they
do that it just doesn't really make any
sense to me and this one really doesn't
make any sense to me like I said why
would they hide it um so yeah the so
like I said there is something called
maybe kind of that the F Zone but it
doesn't have anything to do with the
ocean it's just the the inner and outer
boundary of the Earth's core that's what
they're referring to and like I said I
can only find a couple examples of them
referring to it as that they don't
usually call it that so I guess maybe it
was just whoever wrote this paper the
scientists wrote this paper decided they
were going to call it that so aside from
all that though is it possible that a
Megalodon could still exist like out
there somewhere so um you know obviously
they did really exist at some point
um but it's I don't know it's kind of
doubtful so scientists point out that
you know although the ocean is
massive and there are lots and lots of
undiscovered species some of them
probably quite large uh that we don't
know about um you know they're finding
new stuff all the time um something the
size of a Megalodon would have a very
very noticeable effect on the wider
ecosystem um that you know that would
need to be explained um one of the
things they point out is that Wales only
got generally whales only got as large
as they are now after the Megalodon went
extinct obviously because they weren't
competing with them anymore so they're
like the fact that whales are so big now
it that's kind of one thing that says
probably Megalodons are not around
anymore so according to the fossil
evidence megalodons went extinct about
2.6 million years ago maybe a little
before that now during this period there
was a lot of like Cooling and drying
going on in the
world and what might have caused that
was that there were um there was like a
closing up of the seaways that separated
North from South America and also
Eurasia from
Africa uh also during this period the
ismos of Panama emerged uh you know that
was one of the things that happened
and this probably it happened slowly
obviously but over time it would have
split up populations of prey and
predators and the ocean currents would
have changed um and probably what
happened this is kind of way why they
think the Megalodons went extinct
ultimately was that um because of these
environmental factors like this L these
land walls coming up and the ocean
currents changing and stuff that um the
the e systems that supported baling
whales which feed on Krill and stuff um
were also changed and megalodons mostly
fed on baling whales um also around this
time period great whites and an early
iteration of killer whales were also
evolving to kind of compete more uh in
the same space as a Megalodon would have
um and that probably contributed to
their populations dwindling over that
time
period um so they have
found um you know all of the fossil
teeth and the um vertebrae and stuff
like that from megalodons and where they
found them um were During the period
that they were alive during the masine
and pine periods they were shallow Seas
right now there have been because I
think that a lot of um you know
cryptozoologists and stuff kind of point
this out there were
supposedly some some more recent
Megalodon
teeth um found in
1873 by the HMS Challenger now these
were actually dated in
1959 um supposedly to be between 11,000
and 24,000 years old which obviously is
much newer than the 2.6 million years
ago that they were supposedly have gone
extinct so cryptozoologists often point
to that saying it's like oh see they
could still still be around cuz that
wasn't quite I mean that was still a
long time ago but it's not quite as long
ago so it's still possible they might
still be around um however the uh the
dating that was done in the ' 50s was
later found to be uh erroneous uh what
they think happened with those
particular teeth is that they were um
preserved by this kind of um manganese
dioxide like crust that was on them that
made them appear much newer than they
were um because the decomposition rate
was lower so those teeth are probably
the same age as the other ones it just
so happened in the environmental
conditions that they seemed like they
were newer um so you know so a lot of
people pointed out too well what about
something like the mega mouth shark they
you know that's a big ass shark and they
only just discovered that in the 70s you
know so could it be that the Megalodon
is still alive but in really really deep
water so we don't really see it all that
often which like I said seems reasonable
on its face
but the thing about the Megalodon what
they do know about that animal is that
it actually lived in coastal Waters it
didn't live in deep water Because deep
waterers really cold um it actually
lived in warm Waters and so they think
that probably um it couldn't survive in
uh in deep water because it would be too
cold for them um they also think uh at
least from the evidence that they have
that megalodons they had Nursery for
their babies in um like shallow Seas
like the Mediterranean and the Caribbean
and stuff like that um and they hunted
in you know just the the first couple
hundred meters like beneath where there
was a lot of light still like so in
Shallow Waters is where they hunted
because their main prey uh which were
whales Bing whales um that's kind of
also where they hung out because that's
where all the food was that's where all
the Plankton was so that's where the
Megalodons were as well so it's unlikely
that they lived like way down deep
because they just weren't built for that
at least according to everything they
know so yeah um this was actually like I
said it was this was a pretty
fascinating topic once I went down the
rabbit hole about it even though I was
kind of freaking out when I first
started researching it because I said oh
my God there's like nothing about this
other than this one post on like a
paranormal website and like that Tik Tok
video the two Tik Tok the Tik Tok video
of like the fakey one
about Zone F and then the other one
about the big ass basking shark that was
pretty much it um so I was like well
[__] what am I going to talk about the
whole time and I was like well I guess I
could talk about megalodons and if they
could still be around and stuff I'm not
saying it's not impossible obviously but
you know weirder things have happened
but you know it it's just unlikely it's
it's cool to think well I don't know if
it's cool to think about because sharks
are scary as [__] as they are I don't
need to see one that's like three times
bigger than [__] Jaws you know what I
mean cuz how big was Jaws I know he
wasn't real I know he was mechanical but
I'm just saying how how big was he
supposed to be in the movie didn't he
say didn't quint in Jaws didn't he say
he was 25 or 30 feet now I can't
remember yeah because I thought because
didn't Brody say he's like 20 feet long
and he said and Quint said 25 or did he
say 35 yeah 25 feet okay so I was right
the first time that was right the first
time which like I said that's big I mean
I again I would [__] my pants if I saw a
[__] especially it was a great white
shark that big but a Megalodon is like
three times bigger than
that and it's just could probably
swallow you without even noticing you
know um yeah three that's right I just
cuz I remember I was trying to remember
that scene I just saw Jaws like like
last year I think
again and uh yeah that's right because
bro said he thought it was 20 ft or or
Hooper thought it was 20t I don't
remember but yeah 25 ft so yeah that's a
big ass shark shk but and that's
probably about as big that video that
Tik Tok video I showed you the shark
swimming by the ship that's probably
about how big that shark was like I said
and it looks big like it's you know they
made a whole [__] horror movie about
it Steven Spielberg did um so obviously
that's scary because that's a big
monster shark but that's not as big as a
Megalodon would be a Megalodon would be
[__] three times bigger than that
three times bigger um but yeah so like I
said I don't I don't think it's
impossible that a mega might still be
around but I don't know I just think
it's really really unlikely it' be kind
of cool if they found one but I'm kind
of thinking probably no not something
that size I kind of feel like most of
the [__] they're finding now
is smaller you
know um let's see uh let's see what
everybody's talking about in the because
I was kind of going through the topic so
I didn't really read a lot of people's
comments see a lot of times that's kind
of why it's good to have Tom on the show
too because sometimes when he's talking
I can read everybody's comments because
I don't really like to have dead time
you know that's also why I haven't drunk
my whole drink because I'm not drinking
while he's talking which I guess is good
so I won't get super [__]
up Ouija Jaws sounds like an MST 3K
project in the
making um I was kind of tempted when we
were looking at Christmas horror movies
to talk about I was kind of tempted by
Santa Jaws but um I I don't know I just
didn't pull the trigger on it maybe next
year but there's just there's a
ridiculous ridiculous amount of shark
movies and then you know so obviously
because shark movies are popular you
know when the um megalodon thing came
out on Discovery or whatever they're
just kind of like oh now we're going to
do megalodon ones so there's a [__] ton
of Megalodon ones
too you
know I feel like there's probably more
shark movies than Maybe maybe any other
kind of like horror
movies I just I really wish I'm so
disappointed I just really wish Ouija
shark had been better it was just so CU
I was like man what a great premise I
was like that sounds so stupid and
awesome and it's just kind of like and
it just wasn't it just wasn't funny
enough I was like it needed to be
funnier it needed to be crazier you know
I don't like I said if you're gonna if
you're gonna do a movie like that come
up with a great premise like that like
lean into I think that was the problem I
had too like you know we just reviewed
Ginger dead man with Gary Bucy and I
said I think that was I liked that movie
but the problem I had with it was like
it wasn't funny enough they didn't go
far enough with the with the concept
like cuz that's a hilarious concept I
mean look at all the funny [__] you
could do with that but they just didn't
do there was some funny stuff in there
but it just wasn't it wasn't funny
enough you really got to lean into it
you know if you're going to go that
route make it like like out there and
crazy and I don't understand what they
were doing with the love story in there
either that didn't need to be in
there uh Denny said there was a Sci-Fi
channel movie in the early Millennium
about a giant squid which was decent
yeah I think they made a bunch of squid
ones too cuz um I wish I had a list on
hand of all the Sci-Fi Originals because
some of the titles on there were like
super funny well that was another one we
were thinking of doing when I think when
we were doing Ginger dead man or
whatever but was um scrolling through
the things I was like maybe we should do
lavalantula did we do
lavalantula I kind of remember like
watching it yeah I think we did do it
that one also wasn't as funny as that's
the thing I'm always I'm always
disappointed in them because I'm like
man the the title is so funny and like
the concept is so funny that's going to
be like awesome but it's just never even
shark NATO wasn't as funny as I thought
it should be I mean that's a
hilarious concept it's like you could
have done so much more with that
but it was funny but it just wasn't
funny enough you know what I mean it
wasn't funny enough yeah Ben said Mega
Shark versus Super octopus is good
that's another one that I've kind of
been curious to see I like all those
like big monster movie things but
sometimes I kind of feel like if you're
going to go that route if you're going
to make something called lavalantula for
example don't even bother with like the
human characters don't even bother with
like a human plot don't really I mean
nobody cares the only reason anybody is
watching that movie is to see giant
monsters fight and like people getting
eaten and [__] up and probably the
whole movie should just be that like
don't try to have characters on a plot
and stuff like that it's like nobody
cares about that just have the monster
stuff you know what I mean just make it
kind of like Gonzo porn nobody wants to
see nobody wants to see all the boring
[__] in between nobody wants to see
that um let's see yeah Camp guy said
your lungs won't EXP explode unless you
hold your breath as you ascend yeah I
did yeah I did say that and then I was
like oh wait I don't think your lungs
explode but you know what I mean
um uh Sebastian said Peter benchley
wrote beast and there was a two-part
movie I still haven't read that one I
read
Jaws um and I think interestingly I
think Jaws is one case where well one of
a couple cases that I can think of where
I liked the movie a lot better than the
book there was a lot of other stuff
there was a lot of subplots in the book
and didn't in the book didn't um didn't
Brody's wife have an affair with
Hooper if am I remembering that right
and I was just kind of like I don't like
that well because it just made I don't
know like it made a lot of the human
characters kind of not likable you're
just like yeah let the sharks eat them
whereas just kind of like the movie
everybody was really likable so you were
just kind of like oh no like when Quint
got eaten and everything like that I was
like that was spoiler alert um you know
that that was horrible cuz you liked all
the all the characters
uh Hugo says why NASA oh I did answer
that question earlier I'm not really
sure if you were uh if you were here but
um why NASA got called about a giant
shark because they do actually study the
oceans like from satellites and stuff
like that and they and they um work with
a lot of ocean oceanographic institutes
and things like that studying ocean
stuff because deep ocean and space are
kind of similar so they use it for
research purposes but that's why they
called them I guess and like I said that
um
that video or that thing where I was
where they said that they called NASA
about the giant shark I don't even know
if that's true I just like read that
somewhere so I thought I'd say it but
and I said at the time I was like I'm
not sure if that's true so it's like I
don't know if they just call hey NASA we
saw this big shark you know what I mean
what's going on with that um yeah Camp
guy said you can blow your lungs out
from as shallow as 35 or 40 feet the air
in your lungs will expand two or three
times from that depth yeah so that's
what I I mean that's why I think in this
video the fact that he said he Dove down
600 feet I think that was kind of like
part of the because he's like well
obviously you can't dive down 600 feet
you can but not just like farting around
to look at a cage you know what I mean
Danny says conspiracy theories are good
entertainment they are I don't well like
I said I don't
um I I don't know I have like a weird
like LoveHate relationship with them
like a lot of the times they are kind of
like fun to read about but but I don't
really get too into them because a lot
of people take them seriously and you
know even the Wilder ones and that kind
of like bothers me I guess because it's
just kind of like
man I get kind of like freaked out that
people will believe some stuff like some
conspiracy theories are
obviously way the [__] out there and
obviously cannot be true and it kind of
worries me that there's people out there
like walking around in the world like
maybe stay standing behind me at the
bank or whatever that are actually like
believing that stuff so so it's a little
bit worrisome but you know they but I
mean they're fun if you don't really
believe them all that much because like
I'm a skeptical person I don't really I
don't I don't really truck with any of
that kind of stuff you know what I'm
saying it like I said I know that
conspiracies do exist but um they're
generally successful ones are generally
smaller and successful if it was
successful you wouldn't even know about
it
you know that's what I
figure all of these like World spanning
ones and stuff like that like all that
stupid [__] about you know all the royal
family or reptilians and all this I'm
like that's obviously even all that [__]
about the Illuminati and all that's
obviously not true it's obviously not
true it's any of the ones that are that
big and this one I think counts because
you know thousands and thousands of
people work at Nasa thousands of people
would have to would have to build that
cage thousands of people it would
thousands of people would have to know
about it and it's like the fact that
nobody leaked anything ever like from
the 70s I don't believe it I just don't
believe
it um yeah let's see they're talking
[Music]
about yeah Ben says same as when you
float in space without a space
suit that kind of scares me more well
the ocean scares me a lot but one of the
worst things that I can think of is just
floating
out like one of my worst like a
nightmare that I have sometimes is well
I have a lot of deep ocean ones but like
being out in space and then having your
um you know you're fixing the outside of
the space station or whatever and like
then your tether comes loose and you
just go floating off and [__] oh my
God that would be whenever I see that
happen in a movie it like stresses me
the [__] out like a lot I'm just like
holy [__] even in that shitty ass movie
again that I saw on MST which was um uh
what was that movie called old black and
white movie The Phantom Planet the
Phantom Planet I think it was and um the
one guy like there was two guys on on
the ship and then one of them was on he
got knocked out or something or he had
shrunk down it's a whole thing he shrunk
down he got back in the ship and he was
back to normal size but he was still
unconscious and so like the other guy
that was on the ship um some [__] went
wrong with the ship and he's like oh
[__] I just got to casually walk out on
the wing of the of the ship and fix it
because you can do that um and his
tether came loose and he went floating
off into space and even that and that's
like a [__] shitty ass black and
white movie that was just like it was
really bad but it still like scared the
crap out of me cuz I was thinking about
what that would be like cuz it would
probably take you a while probably take
you a while to die well I don't know how
long it would take but I guess how
however much air you had in your suit
but
yeah Sebastian says Megalodon teeth are
all fake unless someone proves otherwise
all teeth are
fake that's what I mean well see that's
why I wanted to do a show although this
will be I've been wanting to a show
about Evolution versus creationism for a
long time cuz we did Flat Earth and that
was like pretty fun and a lot of the
flat Earth and creationism kind stuff
kind of um overlaps because it's usually
evangelicals that are coming at it from
that uh Sy because you know Flat Earth
is in the Bible and blah blah so um so
that was a fun show to do and I was like
man we should do a creationism show but
I would probably get like so mired in
all because I have I have hundreds of
books probably like hundreds of books
about creationism and like evolutionism
C versus creationism because it's like
something that I'm really fascinated by
because I I'm really into um
evolutionary biology and I used to read
a lot about it so I got kind of off on a
kick for a while and uh they just that
some of the [__] they believe is just
crazy and they and some of the stuff
they say it's like that's kind of the
thing about people that believe in those
kinds of conspiracy theories which I
guess creationism is kind of like that
but um is that no matter how much they
they keep saying show me evidence of
this show me evidence of that so they're
like here and then they show it to you
but they're well that's not real so it's
like what's the point then like I I
don't understand what the point is with
arguing with them because they're not
going to believe anything that you show
them because they've already made their
mind out you know what I mean they they
say that they want to see evidence for
[__] but you show them evidence of it
and they just don't believe you so oh
it's fake that's just what they'll say
so I don't I don't really know why you
would bother engaging but I don't know
there there's a there was a whole like
years back there was a whole debate with
Scientists it's like should we cuz you
know there was kind of some high profile
scientists that were asked to like
debate some high-profile cre
creationists and some scientists said no
we should do it because you know other
people might see it that are on the
fence and it's like we might convince
them um you know and but then like some
other scientists were like I don't think
you should because that legitim
legitimizes their craziness and it's
like we don't want to make it look like
there is an actual debate because
there's not um you know so I'm not
really sure where I fall on it I can
kind of see I can kind of see both sides
there's there's good points on both
sides but I don't even know like I said
I don't even think a lot of those
debates that happened you know the
creationists are not interested
in
um in in having a reasonable debate
about it um they're interested in
pushing their uh agenda and owning the
scientists and making it look like they
own the SC even if they didn't they'll
that's what they'll tell people and they
people will believe it you know what I
mean so I I don't really see any point
to it but
if some scientist want to do it I guess
that's up to them I wouldn't be able to
do it I would just like try to talk to
them for 5 seconds and like you know
what I'm just gonna leave or I'm going
to hit you you know what I mean I just
get like super frustrated so they just
have like a lot more patience than I
have I I have none especially not with
people like that but uh but yeah let me
see what else um Tammy said George
Clooney did that in a movie to save
Sandra bulock just floated out into
outer space holy [__] [__] who would
do that to save Sandra Bullock what
movie was that I feel like I know but I
what George cloney and Sandra Bullock in
a space
movie what movie was that I feel like I
should know that but I don't I've never
seen it
obviously so was it so it was like a
Titanic situation
where where where he's just like hey I'm
just gonna float off and I'll just let
you live you know what I mean gravity oh
that's right okay yeah I did not see
that I've been mean to see it I just
didn't get around to it you know what I
mean uh Danny said I just got Oblivion
on Blu-ray I really like that movie
actually that's the Tom Cruz one right
and like you guys know I don't usually
like Tom Cruz but I actually really did
like that movie I thought it was good
he's good in some
things you know he just mostly gets on
my nerves but I can watch him in some
stuff like funny George CL now I'm gonna
think about George Cy Flo off in his
face and Sandra bull
like I'm I'm going have to see that
movie I guess I'm G to have to see that
movie um all right so I
guess all right so I guess I'm gonna
wrap this up like I said I know I've
only been on for an hour and a half
which isn't very long for the show but
you know Tom's not here to make all his
Wise Cracks and I still have a whole
almost a whole uh RAM and passion fruit
drink to finish you know because I
haven't really got a chance to drink it
um but yeah I'm going to go kind of hang
out and wait for Tom to get home he
should be home hopefully in a couple of
hours and uh so we'll see how that goes
I'm going to chill out and watch a movie
or something like that and wait for him
to come home but yeah thanks everybody
for dropping by this evening thanks for
super
chats and uh you know I'm just glad he's
going to be back so we so we should be
able to just do the Sidetrack show on
Friday night like usual Friday night I
think is momento Mory too so I'm not
really sure if we're going out Friday
night he I mean I don't know if he's
going to feel like it we'll see how it
goes um so we might be going out Friday
night but we'll do the Sidetrack show um
anyway so like I said that'll be cool
that he'll be back I'm excited about it
hopefully y'all are excited about it too
uh mango said does Roman passion fruit
work I should try it it's pretty good oh
Tom says I'm here now holy [__] how'd
you get here so fast are you in the are
like what are you in the driveway
do you mean you're in the driveway or
you're in oh you're halfway here oh
okay oh that's
[Laughter]
good oh okay he's got to drive all right
so he's halfway here so it's probably
yeah so it'll probably be like a few
more hours just like I thought so it's 9
o' yeah so like another three hours
another four hours something like that
oh I'm glad you popped in and said
something
because I was for a second I thought are
you texting or are you messaging from
the
drive it's like how'd you get here so
fast gotta drive all this in yeah I'm
about to wrap it up actually because I
kind of went through all the topic
already so because it wasn't like a huge
topic you know what I mean uh but yeah
uh Roman passion fruit work yeah it's
it's pretty good actually it's pretty
good well this is the passion fruit that
you get from like
the um the
international aisle in the grocery store
you know like the what's the brand I
can't remember but yeah yeah access
shows over
time that's okay he's got to drive well
yeah now he's got to like change the
thing because it's like I mean unless
you want to just go ahead and do a
Sidetrack show but I don't know what
else we could talk
about I thought about doing that
but Tammy says Tom speed it up so you
can be on time for for your
pegging we're never going to let that go
okay I'll go back to listening to Wang
he says yeah because I've been on for
like an hour and a half and like like I
said it was a it was kind of a short
topic and uh but yeah so all right so
I'm GNA wrap it up finish my drink I'm
GNA go watch a movie uh somebody
recommended a movie for me to watch
tonight I got to find it on Netflix and
uh so I'll just chill out and wait for
Tom to get back got a few more hours and
uh you know so I'm going to try and keep
my [__] together for that length of time
uh but yeah thanks everybody for hanging
out with me tonight keeping me company
and I will see you guys hopefully both
of us will see you on Friday night good
night